la séance est
ouverte le contendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le procès
verbal est donc adopté sous les réserves
d'usage madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
et sur notre site
internet chacun observera les valeurs
qui sont pour nous importantes le
respect des uns et des autres et une
valeur concrète et le respect du temps
de parole ça vaut pour les
parlementaires comme pour les ministres
la parole à l'exception de la première
ministre la parole est à Pascal Alizard
pour le gros
républicain monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre mes chers collègues dans la
situation actuelle je tenais à saluer
l'initiative d'une marche contre
l'antisémitisme lancé par le président
Larcher et la présidente brun
Pivet ce fut je le crois nous le croyons
un bel événement de cohésion nationale
auquel comme d'autres j'ai regretté
l'absence du président Macron l'attaque
du Hamas survenue le 7 octobre 2023 sur
le seul israélien à frappé le monde
d'ffroid plus de 2000 terroristes
islamistes ont assassiné méthodiquement
1200 personnes capturé 240 otages 40 de
nos compatriotes sont morts sont portés
disparus dont certains sont autage dans
ce contexte dramatique la sinueuse
straté française déroute les Français
comme nos partenaires internationaux
après avoir rappelé la ligne de la
France il semble que le chef de l'État a
enchaîné les initiatives controversées
aujourd'hui c'est autour d'un éventuel
cessellefeu qui pourrait être mis à
profit par les terroristes que les
incompréhensions se cristallisent nos
diplomates les plus chevrenés expriment
des doutes et des inquiétudes même une
certaine presse qui vous est
habituellement favorable exprime graves
réservve madame la ministre en fait ma
question est simple quelle est la
cohérence de tout cela et quelle
initiative d'enverdure concertter et
expliquer la France compte-elle enfin
promouvoir pour sortir de cette
crise répondre la parole est au ministre
délégué en charge du commerce extérieur
des Fronçais de l'étranger Monsieur
Olivier
bestch merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Alizard
la position de la France est claire
depuis le 7 octobre depuis le 7 octobre
c'est-à-dire l'attaque du groupe
terroriste Hamas sur Israël nous avons
évidemment condamné cette attaque et
affirmer le droit d'Israël à se défendre
légitimement dans le cadre du respect du
droit international et du droit
humanitaire nous avons demandé la
libération et sans condition de
l'ensemble des otages nous n'avons
jamais fait l'assimilation entre le
Hamas et le peuple palestinien nous
avons organisé ici même à Paris une
conférence humanitaire pour Gaza réunie
1 milliard d'euros pour l'aide
humanitaire et demander à ce que cette
humanitaire puisse être acheminé
directement à Gaza nous mettons tout en
œuvre sur un plan sécuritaire pour
éviter
que la région ne s'embrase avec deux
visites de la ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères Madame Catherine
Colona dont j'excuse aujourd'hui
l'absence puisqu'elle accompagne le
président de la République dans sa
visite d'État en Suisse le ministre des
Armées Sébastien Lecornu est en ce
moment même également dans les pays du
golf pour travailler à cette action
diplomatique et éviter une extension du
conflit nous travaillons également sur
le plan humanitaire je l'ai dit pour
faire en sorte que cette aide soit
acheminée à Gaza et enfin nous
travaillons sur le plan politique pour
faire en sorte que lorsque la trêve
humanitaire que nous demandons aura
débouché sur un cess de feu nous
puissions reprendre un processus
politique qui permette la coexistence du
peuple palestinien et de l'État d'Israël
la solution à deux États qui est la
seule qui permette à de peuples de vivre
en paix et en sécurité l'un à côté de
l'autre
merci Monsieur le Ministre la diplomatie
gaulienne c'est d'être en capacité de
parler à tout le monde et non pas de
dire à chacun ce qu'il a envie
d'entendre entre cavalier seul et leçon
de morale nous appliquons les mêmes
recettes qui nous ont malheureusement
déjà tant d servis dans l'Union
européenne et à l'internationale
dernièrement les relations sont tendus
avec les Israéliens en raison de
déclarations ambigues du chef de l'État
quant aux pays arabes ils n'ont fait que
de nous recevoir poliment je précise ce
n'est pas notre outil diplomatique qui
est en cause mais je le crois
profondément le pilotage politique au
plus haut niveau
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Bernard pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie hier
matin monsieur le ministre vous avez
annoncé un accord entre l'État et EDF
sur le prix de l'électricité nucléaire
un accord d'une importance majeure pour
nos concitoyens mais aussi pour nos
entreprises et nos collectivités un
accord où EDF s'engage à vendre son
électricité nucléaire à un prix évalué à
70 € le mgawh en moyenne après un an de
négociation intense et après avoir
obtenu gain de cause au niveau européen
sur la décorrélation du coût de
l'électricité de celui des énergies
fossiles notamment du gaz la France
reprend enfin le contrôle sur les prix
de l'électricité de plus alors que la
régulation actuelle ne portait que sur
un/ers de la production ce nouvel accord
porte sur l'intégralité de l'électricité
produite ceci permet à EDF de gagner en
visibilité ce qui est essentiel pour un
acteur industriel cela l'IT égal ement
pour nos concitoyens et nos
collectivités par ailleurs je me réjouis
que le tarif réglementé de vente soit
préservé pour les ménages et les TPE
tout comme je le soulligne avec
satisfaction le fait qu'il soit
simplifié en supprimant le seuil fixé à
36 kov en si les raisons d'applaudir une
telle entente sont nombreuses force est
de constater que nous devons apporter
des précisions aux consommateurs par
conséquent monsieur le ministre quel
sera l'impact de cet accord sur la des
concitoyens et des entreprises en 2025
enfin si ce Pact permettra de préserver
la situation financière des DF comment
s'appliquerail aux opérateurs
alternatifs je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la Paro minist de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle Monsieur le Maire la parole
monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le
président vous retrouver parce
que nous avons passé près de 2 heures
ensemble à la commission des affaires
économiques hier au
Sénat commission particulièrement
constructive et efficace je tiens à le
dire je ne suis jamais aussi heureux que
lorsque je suis au Sénat vous le
voyez cet accord vous l'avez
parfaitement dit monsieur le sénateur
c'est un accord stratégique pour la
nation française d'abord il a été permis
je rends hommage le travail qui été fait
par agès punach par l'accord trouvé par
la ministre de l'énergie en Europe qui
nous permet de décou définitivement les
prix de l'électricité en France des prix
du gaz deuxième remarque cet accord ne
s'applique qu'à partir du 1er janvier
2026 donc en 2025 la situation reste
inchangée pour les ménages comme pour
les entreprises trè élément que vous
avez souligné qui est absolument décisif
l'immense intérêt de cet accord c'est
qu'il s'applique sur 100 % la production
électrique nucléaire de DF donc quand
j'entends les comparaison ce matin à la
radio ou à la télévision entre 42 € le
MWh aujourd'hui et demain 70 € de mgaw
je comprends l'inquiétude des
entrepreneurs des industriels des
ménages qui disent ma facture va
augmenter de plus de 60 % sauf que les
42 € le mgawh pent sur 1/ers de la
production les 70 € en moyenne sur 100 %
de la production quand vous allez à la
boulangerie quand vous achetez tout le
gâteau c'est plus cher qu'une seule part
du gâteau cet accord il permet de
garantir par conséquent la compétitivité
de nos entreprises industrielles c'était
l'objectif numéro 1 nous aurons nous
aurons un des prix
pour une fois que je vous vois j'en
profite pour parler avec amitié cet
accord il garantit la compétitivité de
nos entreprises industrielles avec un
des prix les plus compétitifs de tous
les pays européens c'était notre
priorité absolue en deuxème lieu il
garantit la stabilité au ménag c'était
notre deuxième priorité il n'y aura pas
de ressaut entre fin 25 et début 2026
puisque les prix seront étalés dans le
temps nous ne voulons pas que les
ménages connaissent à nouveau
l'explosion des prix qu'ils ont connu
pendant la crise énergétique enfin en
3oisème lieu le garantie de rentabilité
de DF c'est pas parce que DF est à 100 %
public qu'elle doit perdre de l'argent
enfin vous l'avez dit c'était réclamé
par les sénateurs désormais les tarifs
régulés s'appliqueront à toutes les TPE
quelle que soit leur puissance même si
elles sont au-dessus de 36 kV ampè
c'était une demande des sénateurs nous y
avons donc
répondu monsieur
buis la parole à notre collègue Pierre
Jean Rochet pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et
territoire monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la France entière est traumatisée par la
multiplication des actes antisémites
dans notre pays ils appellent une
condamnation unanime je profite
d'ailleurs de mon intervention pour vous
remercier monsieur le Président ainsi
que madme la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale d'avoir organisé cette marche
contre l'antisémitisme et pour la
République qui fut un réel succès bravo
nous ne devons pas tolérer le cancer de
la haine au sein de notre nation ce
cancer n'est hélas pas nouveau nous le
pensions en rémission mais les
événements du Proche Orient le mois
dernier ont entraîné une forte
résurgence de ces actes monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous donner le
bilan exact de ces agressions combien
ont fait l'objet de poursuite et de
condamnation les Français ont besoin de
savoir ils attendent de la fermeté dans
la réponse
judiciaire conjointement par des
incitations à la haine relayé sur les
réseaux sociaux des puissances
étrangères tentent de déstabiliser notre
pays l'affaire des couples moldav
peignant des étoiles de David sur des
immeubles en est la dernière
illustration monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous dire pourquoi les
intéressés n'ont-ils pas fait l'objet de
poursuite de poursuite pénale pourquoi
ont-ils simplement été expulsés que
savez-vous de leurs commanditair dont la
presse semble unanime à désigner les
services de renseignement russe d'autres
actions similaires de la part de ces
mêmes services ont-ell été identifié au
cours de ces dernières années des
conséquences diplomatiques en
seront-elles tirées si cette piste est
confirmée la désinformation et les
manœuvres de la cybergerre sont en train
de tuer la démocratie nous en sommes
depuis longtemps déjà la cible tant à
l'étranger que sur notre propre sol il
nous faut répondre comment le
gouvernement lutte-t-il contre les
tentatives étrangère de désinformation
je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la Paro est
min érieur Monsieur
géraldenin Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le
sénateur effectivement depuis le 7
octobre pardon mais déjà très présent en
France depuis le 1er janvier des actes
où les événements antisémites se sont
multipliés à l'heure où je vous parle
c'est 1762 événements ou actes
antisémites qui ont été constatés par
les policiers et gendarmes extrêmement
nombreux vous savez plus de 10000
personnes dans les 950 lieux que les fr
Françis de confessions juives
fréquentent le plus notamment les écoles
ou les synagogues qui ont donné lieu à
571 inter 571 pardon interpellation dont
130 étrangers je veux dire que sur les
130 étrangers les 45 qui étaient
étrangers en sitation irrégulières sont
tous mis dans les centes de rétention
administratif et ont on a commencé
commencé leur expulsion du territoire
national les autres se voir retirer leur
titre de séjour de façon systématique à
ma demande 8952 signalement sur Faros la
plateforme numérique du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui a donné lieu à 350
judiciarisations vous me posez par
ailleurs la la question de cette affaire
de couple moldave je metes couple avec
un S qui serait l'auteur de ces graffiti
d'étoil de David qui auraiit été posé
sur un certain nombre de sites de
maisons d'appartements où des Français
de confession juives habiteraient les
deux couples ont quitté le territoire
national le premier a été interpellé et
expulsé en effet après des
interrogatoires et puis nous avons avons
des éléments extrêmement précis qui nous
amènent à penser qu'en effet un
commanditaire étranger est en
responsabilité dans cette situation une
affaire une information judiciaire a été
ouverte sur ce que je peux vous dire
donc il y a donc des poursuites pénales
c'est qu'il s'agit du commanditaire qui
serait en effet étranger ou qu'il
s'agisse de ces personnes qui venaient
d'arriver sur le territoire national qui
ont été expulsé du territoire national
les services d'enquête confié par les
juges d'instructions sera un service
d'enquête spécialisé qui je crois répond
en partie à votre interrogation sur les
ingérances étrangère et sur les soupçons
que l'État peut avoir je veux dire par
ailleurs qu'il y a d'autres graffiti des
étoiles de David ou des croixgamés qui
sont mis partout sur le territoire
national qui ne sont pas l'auteur eux de
couple Bulgar ou d'ING gérance étrangère
supposé mais bien d'antisémite organisés
qui sont interpellés et bien sûr déférés
devant toutes les décisions prises par
le
parquet monsieur
Rochet la parole est notre collègue
Michel Massier pour le gros du
Rassemblement démocratique et soci
européen vous avez la
parole euh monsieur le Président Madame
le première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre Dominique fort vendredi
dernier vous étiz avec Madame le premier
ministres aux assis du département de
France vous avez tenté les rassurer tant
sur leur moyens que sur leur avenir
institutionnel notamment troublé par la
nouvelle émission vers force de
constater que l'effort consenti par
votre gouvernement pas totalement au
besoins exprimés par le département qui
à la défaveur d'un terrible effet ciseau
traverse une très grave crise financière
lié à deux points la contraction des
frais de nota donc les DMTO et à
l'augmentation des dépenses
sociales vous avez rappelé le rôle
indispensable des départements il s'agit
aujourd'hui de les soutenir pour
infin vous le savez maintenir la
démocratie locale et leur
investissement dans le cas contraire
vous risqueriez de mettre à mal toute
l'édifice solidaire de notre
décentralisation je pense bien sûr aux
éepad aux 10 au
PMI mais également au servicees de soins
en domicile au collège tant de services
indispensables à notre quotidien dans
nos
territoire fraîchement élu du lotgaron
et ancien vice-président de ce
département je demeure attaché à cette
collectivité de proximité qui supplit
les services de l'État notamment dans
les territoires ruraux ainsi madame la
ministre comptez-vous intégrer dans
l'examen des projets de loi en cours des
mesures plus que significatives pour
permettre aux départements de retrouver
leur autonomie financière et assurer
sereinement leur mission de
solidarité pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Michel
massé vous faites référence à l'
interprétation du président François
sauvadé euh cette interpellation à
destination de la première ministre
vendredi dernier en clôture du congrès
annuel de l'Association des départements
de France cette interpellation traduit
une inquiétude de disparition de
l'échelon départemental inquiétude que
je dois vous avouer je perçois aussi le
président de la
République s'interroge tout simplement
sur le mil le millefeuil territorial et
a engagé une réflexion sur notre
organisation territoriale il a ai
confier une mission à Eric ver une
mission parlementaire ces travaux
tiendront compte de l'importance de
l'échelon départemental à une époque où
nos concitoyens réclament de la
proximité en toute chose proximité dans
l'état et notre gouvernement s'est
montré je le pense que nous avons le
souci de maintenir cette proximité de la
recréer là où elle n'existe pas
suffisamment où elle n'existe plus sur
bien des sujets aménagement du
territoire politique sociale transition
écologique aussi service public la
maille départementale est une maille
pertinente qui permet de travailler à
l'échelle de territoire cohérent tout en
gardant cette capacité d'action de
proximité à laquelle nous sommes
extrêmement attaché notre réflexion se
fera donc à l'on du rôle essentiel des
départements dans l'actuelle
organisation territoriale j'en suis
convaincu comme la première ministre qui
sait apprécier la juste contribution des
départements à la vitalité des
territoires et qui le leur a dit
vendredi dernier je veux quand même
rappeler avant de conclure euh le
soutien financier que le gouvernement et
les moyens euh accord au département et
que le gouvernement a débloqué 150
millions d'euros pour l'autonomie 100
millions d'euros pour répondre à la
problématique des mineurs non
accompagnés et 100 millions d'euros pour
les départements en situation de
fragilité oui monsieur le sénateur nous
veillons sur nos départements je vous
remercie
B les départements madame la ministre
vous vous le savez sont des
collectivités essentielles pour
l'équilibre dans nos territoire
premierers financeur de la solidarité
premierers aménageurs ils sont
aujourd'hui les acteurs publics locaux
reconnus de l'égalité et du maintien des
services publics rétablir l'autonomie
financière des département est un enjeu
qui dépasse le seuil le seul échalon
départemental j'espère j'espère donc
votre soutien plein et entier pour le
maintien des départements au sein de
l'architecture territoriale et de figer
nos territoires
actuels
la parole est à notre collègue Bernard
jaumier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nous examinons cette semaine
au Sénat le budget de la Sécurité
sociale présenté par le
gouvernement vous nous présenter un
budget qui est en déficit de 8 milliards
pour 2023 qui le sera de 11 en000
et 17 en
2027 c'est une trajectoire qui est
totalement inédite alors que la crise
sanitaire et ses effets sont derrière
nous alors ma question elle est très
simple pourquoi nêes-vous pas capable de
ramener les finances sociales à
l'équilibre avez-vous baissé les bras
avez-vous
renoncé répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la
prévention
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le le Gouvernement présente en
effet un projet de loi financement de la
sécurité sociale qui ramène le déficit
de la branche maladie qui était de 22
milliards l'an dernier à 8,8 milliards
d'euros sur un total de 255 milliards
d'euros de dépenses vos collègues qui
siègent à la commission des finances
seraient sans doute heureux de connaître
ce ratio de de déficit
euh mais vous avez raison un déficit
plus lourd dans la durée n'est pas
soutenable il n'est pas soutenable parce
que l'assurance maladie n'appartient pas
à l'état elle appartient aux assurés
elle a elle est gérée par les
partenaires sociaux sous le et le
gouvernement n'en est que le que le
garant c'est pourquoi dans ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale nous avançons et je l'ai formulé
dans la discussion générale sur une
ligne de crête qui quelquefois vous
conduit du reste à des critiques des
deux côtés de cette ligne de crête à la
fois permettre et mobiliser les moyens
notamment renforcer les moyens dans le
champ de la prévention assurer
l'augmentation des rémunérations des
soignants financer le Ségure de la santé
mais de l'autre côté ralentir la
dynamique de certaines dépenses
notamment les dépenses de soins de ville
notamment les dépenses de médicaments
qui ont augmenté l'an dernier de 7 % et
que nous devons absolument ralentir à
l'heure où je vous parle monsieur le
sénateur les disc discussions entre les
médecins et l'assurance maladie sont en
train de reprendre un des axes majeurs
qui réconciliie selon moi les objectifs
de santé publique et les objectifs de
finances publiqu c'est celui du travail
sur lequel tous les syndicats de
médecins sont prêts à s'engager quel que
soit leur composition ou leur sociologie
c'est celui de la pertinence des soins
et c'est aussi et c'est très important
parce que la pertinence c'est là où se
rejoint la santé publique et la maîtrise
de nos dépenses et par ailleurs la
prévention doit sans doute aujourd'hui
faire l'objet d'une réflexion plus large
sur son financement puisque quand nous
finançons achetons des vaccin HPV pour
cette année c'est pour éviter des
cancers dans 30 ans donc je l'ai dit
nous sommes prêts aussi à ouvrir ce
débat sur le financement de la
prévention merci monsieur le
sénateur merci monsieur le ministre pour
votre réponse j'ai interrogé le
gouvernement sur le déficit de la
Sécurité sociale et vous m'avez répondu
sur le déficit du budget santé
une toute petite partie de la réponse je
n'ai entendu dans vos propos aucune
volonté voilà aucune forte dans une
trajectoire de retour à l'équilibre rien
donc en 2027 quand le chef de l'État
finira son deuxème mandat il laissera
des finances sociales plus dégradées
qu'à son arrivée et largement on pourra
accepter ses déficits parlons du budget
santé si les indicateurs de santé du
pays s'amélioraient mais nous reculons
la 6e à la 13e place en terme
d'espérance de vie à la naissance et la
mortalité infantile progresse nous
pourrions accepter des déficit si
l'hôpital allait mieux qu'il y a 5 ou 6
ans mais l'hôpital se dégrade les
personnels s'en vont et l'offre de soins
se contracte nous pourrions accepter des
déficites si nos concitoyens sur tout le
territoire avaient accès aux soins de
proximité avait accès à un médecin
généraliste mais les déserts médicaux se
répandent et les pénuries çaroisse vous
êtes donc en échec ce sont des vagues de
mauvais résultats dans un océan de
déficit monsieur le ministre votre
gouvernement gère mal la sécurité
sociale la
parole de notre collègue
kathyopoli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen
écologiste monsieur le ministre le pcalé
connaît depuis 2 semaines le les
inondations les plus catastrophiques du
siècle plus d'un tiers des communes
boucher habitation entreprise
exploitation agricole ou bâtiments
publics je tiens à saluer l'immense
courant de solidarité de tout le pays
qui apporte un peu de chaleur aux
population dans ce moment dramatique la
très forte implication des élus locaux
en particulier des maires au côté des
sinistrés jour et nuit ces mes si
souvent décriés parfois découragés font
la démonstration une fois de plus de
leur dévouement ils souhaitent une
simplification des procédures pour leur
permettre d'intervenir sur l'entretien
démaré défaussé entre autres merci à
tous ces volontaires anonymes
association pompiers sécurité civile
agents communaux et services de l'État
qui font un travail admirable la visite
du président de la République nous donne
l'espoir d'une application durable de
l'état où les premiers actes attendus
par la population pour résoudre les
problèmes ont été posé les 50 milliards
d'euros d' d'IDE d'urgence sont un
premier pas mais d'évidence nonobstant
la participation des assurances les
investissements nécessaires pour
reconstruire pu prévenir de telles
catastrophes vont exploser cette
enveloppe c'est d'un véritable plan
marchant pour le pas de calé monsieur le
ministre dont nous avons besoin
l'immensité des problèmes à résoudre le
relogement de nos populations dans le
désespoir ne doivent pas nous exonérer
de réfléchir déjà aux mesures
structurelles à prendre des mesures
techniques bas de rétention d'eau
entretien des écluses et des pompes et
des voitringues et cetera et cetera
offront rapidement des perspectives
posons les premiers actes faute de quoi
les entreprises vont partir les
agriculteurs jeter l'éponge et la
désespérance s'ancrée dans la population
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
éclairer sur la réflexion de l'État et
la réponse qu'il entend apporter aux
propositions des présidents de la région
des haut-- France et au président du
département du pcalis je vous remercie
pour répondre la parole ministre de
l'Intérieur
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président
Madame la la sénatrice avec Christophe
Béchu dès le premier jour dans votre
département dans notre région puis le
président de la République avec
Christophe Béchu et le ministre
d'agriculture nous sommes évidemment au
côté des habitants du pcalé et du Nord
puisque le Nord a été aussi touché
notamment dans sa côté Flandre
singulièrement évidemment devant des
inondations qui sont extrêmement
impressionnantes et qui font suite à une
tempête celle qu' a touché l'ouest de la
France si jeux dire les les personnes du
pas decalé ont connu à la fois la
tempête avec des submersions et puis ces
inondations qui continu et qui sont
encore extrêmement importantes sur le
sur le terrain je voudrais d'abord
remercier les services de secours quel
qu'ils soit les policiers les gendarmes
la protection civile la sécurité civil
6000 personnes ont été évacuées et des
incidents qui sont extrêmement graves de
façon matérielle mais qui heureusement
ne l'ont pas été euh sur les questions
personnelles puisque je crois que le
travail très important qu'on fait
notamment les sapurs pompiers plus de
1000 SAP pompiers dont la moitié sont
venus soit des militaires du ministère
de l'intérieur soit des autres
départements de France ont montré la
solidarité que que vous évoquez nous
avons réuni avec le ministre en charge
de la transition écologique dès hier la
réforme la commission catastrophe
naturelle puisque nous avons 191
communes qui ce matin au Journal
officiel dans votre département ont été
reconnus en catastrophe naturelle une
vingtaine dans le Nord et 30 encore
communes qui ne sont pas concerné mais
qui doivent déposer leur dossier on sait
que c'est toujours difficile il y aura
donc une session de rattrapage bien
évidemment la prochaine semaine le
président de la République a annoncé un
sous-préfet pour le pas decalé et pour
le nord pour organiser en effet cette
simplification je viendrai samedi dans
votre département samedi après-midi de
nouveau pour pouvoir installer ce
sous-préfet réunir les élus et
évidemment être à l'écoute pour
notamment demander aux assureurs de
remplir leurs tâches là où l'État a fait
la sienne notamment sur ce qui concerne
les catastrophes naturelles je laisserai
le ministre en charge de la transition
écologique il a d'autres questions
répondre sur l'écirage et sur les
dotations d'investissement qui peuvent
concerner les
communes la parole est à notre collègue
Amel gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des
territoires depuis une quinzaine de
jours le département du Pas de calis
j'en parle à nouveau sujet qui vient
d'être évoqué subit des inondations
exceptionnelles alors même qu'il avait
été fragilisé par la tempête siarrant
quelques jours auparavant ce sont près
de 250 communes impactées par des
épisodes de pluie torrentiell de cru et
d'inondation sans précédent aussi bien
en terme de durée que d'intensité en
terme de précipitation il est tombé en
un mois ce qui tombe habituellement en 6
mois les dernières annonces du
gouvernement vont dans le bon sens
l'état de catastrophe naturelle prononcé
pour 244 communes du nord et du pcalais
j'en profite pour ajouter que d'autres
départements sont touchés dans les haut
de France mais pas que ainsi donc un
fond de soutien de 50 millions d'euros à
destination des collectivités bien sûr
une première enveloppe bienvenue mais
bien évidemment insuffisante au regard
des dégâts monsieur le ministre la
visite du président de la République
hier à SaintOmer a révélé des besoins
criants des sinistrés des communes pour
faire face à cette catastrophe des
besoins pour gérer l'urgence mais
également des besoins en matière de
prévention les attentes sont de tout
ordre financier juridique opérationnel
financièrement d'abord il est impossible
aujourd'hui d'avancer un chiffrage des
dégâts des désordres pour les habitants
mais également pour nos commerçants
artisans agriculteurs entrepreneurs par
contre il est indispensable de veiller à
simplifier à accélérer les procédures
administratives pour permettre à chacun
de reprendre une vie normale
juridiquement ensuite les élus dont je
salue l'investissement entier auprès de
leurs administratiers vous demande
encore de leurs administrés pardon vous
demande encore de la souplesse dans
l'exercice de leurs compétences
faciliter l'entretien des cours d'eau
par exemple des faussés ils sont
encadrés par trop de normes et de
contraintes qui tiennent et
essentiellement des conditions
environnementales excessives monsieur le
ministre vous le savez avec le
réchauffement climatique ce risque
d'événement risque de se multiplier les
séquelles sont matériel mais également
psychologi la confiance la question
pardon est de savoir aujourd'hui comment
vous allez redonner confiance à nos
concitoyens je vous
remercie pour répond la parole ministre
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des
territoires monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice gaker vous l'avez
dit pas plus tard qu'hier vous étiez
présente pour la visite du président de
la République quand avec Olivier
Grégoire avec Marc fenau nous avons été
à la rencontre des des sinistré des
communes concernées et ça faisait suite
à la visite que géralde armanin leur
avait rendu dès la semaine dernière
d'abord aujourd'hui même une proposition
de simplification sur les curages des
rivières a été transmis au Conseil
d'État ce sujet il ne concerne pas que
le nord et les haut de France il est
attendu dans divers territoires vous
vous doutez bien que si on l'a transmis
dès aujourd'hui c'est qu'on y
travaillait depuis un certain temps déjà
nous étions arrivés à une copie
permettant de concilier ces impératifs
écologiques et ces besoins de prévention
que vous évoqué je veux rendre justice
madame la sénatrice d'abord aux
institutions et aux élus locaux de ce
territoire qui ont par les travaux
qu'ils ont conduit fait alors que nous
avons vous l'avez dit des niveaux
historiques de cru sur les rivières de
ce territoire nous n'avons pas eu autant
de sinistrés qu'il y a 20 ans parce que
les digues les dispositifs de bassin le
suivi qui ont eu lieu dans tous les
divers territoires ont permis de porter
leurs fruits en revanche on doit trouver
un meilleur équilibre entre la poursuite
d'un principe de précaution qui a permis
de montrer ces résultats et le fait de
pas aller trop loin dans des exigences
qui finissent par heurter le bon sens et
par limiter la capacité d'intervenir au
milieu de tout ça il y a l'urgence 50
millions ur annoncés qui vont permettre
et c'est un début d'accompagner les
collectivités pour les infrastructures
pour les ouvrages d'art de manière sans
attendre à pouvoir les accompagner le
travail de consolidation des dégâts la
reconnaissance de catastrophes
naturelles déclaré hier par le ministre
de l'Intérieur et un travail qui va se
poursuivre quand l'eau va véritablement
baisser ce qu'on espère pour le début de
la semaine prochaine pour tirer toutes
les conséquences en terme de prévention
et en terme de suivi merci la parole est
à notre collègue Daniel salmon pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité
ir merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues demain
jeudi 16 novembre les États-membres de
l'Union européenne sont appelés à voter
sur la réautorisation pour 10 ans du
glyphosate ce vote dans lequel la France
aura un rôle déterminant à une
importance cruciale alors que l'preuve
s'accumule sur les dangers pour la santé
et l'environnement de cette molécule
vous le savez le glyphosate est classé
comme cancérogène probable depuis 2015
par le Centre international de recherche
sur le cancer linerme en 2021 insistait
quant à lui sur son potentiel comme
perturbateur endocrinien et son lien
avec des maladies neurodégénératives ces
jours derniers l'fsa a reconnu des
défaillances elle-même dans ses
méthodologies d'évaluation du risque si
la France s'abstient à nouveau demain
sur le glyphosate elle aura une lourde
responsabilité pourtant on s'en souvient
le président de la République annoncéit
en 2017 une sortie de son usage en
France sous 3 ans souhaitant entraîner
l'Europe entière derrière lui
aujourd'hui on constate un abandon de
tout leadership sur la question la
France a quitté le wagon de tête pour
être en queue de train avec un discours
à géométrie variable un jour le prétexte
national pour l'inaction et la
distorsion de concurrence avec nos
voisins et aujourd'hui vous ne montrez
aucune ambition au niveau de l'Union
européenne alors que d'autres
États-membres ont pris des positions
bien plus courageuse aussi Monsieur le
Ministre la France votera-t-elle contre
la réautorisation du glyphosate et ê-v
prêt à jouer votre rôle pour son
interdiction rapide au niveau européen
on répondre la
paroleagriculture la souveraineté
alimentaire Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur salmon
comme vous le savez demain c'est la
commission d'appel au fond de du sujet
sur la réhomologation du glyphosate la
position de la France sur ce sujetl dans
le cadre de la perspective de
homologation est la même depuis le début
nous n'étions pas d'accord et nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec la position de
la Commission telle qu'elle est formulée
qui était une position en terme de durée
et en terme d'usage qui ne correspondait
pas à la ligne que la France a choisi et
permettez-moi de vous le dire j'en suis
désolé que la France a plutôt un
leadership puisque c'est le seul pays
d'Europe et du monde qui a pris des des
mesures d'ors et déjà de restriction
d'un certain nombre d'usages et les
résultats pardon sont au rendez-vous
puisqu'on a réduit les usages de 27 à 30
%. après nous sommes dans un cadre
européen il faut reconnaître monsieur
salmon parce qu'il y a aussi des
principes de réalité qui s'imposent il y
a des usages pour lequels nous ne sommes
aujourd'hui en impasse je pense à
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
j'imagine que vous la défendez
puisqu'elle permet d' améliorer la
qualité des sols d'améliorer la
productivité et de stocker plus de
carbone aujourd'hui à date au moment où
je vous parle il n'y a pas d'alternative
crédiible et donc la position de la
France la position de la France elle est
simple partout où on peut réduire les
les usages conformément à la trajectoire
que nous nous sommes donnés nous le
faisons et là où il y a des impasses on
assume aussi les positions qui sont les
nôtres donc on continuera à défendre au
niveau européen la volonté de réduire
l'usage du glyphosate et en même temps
de prendre acte des solutions d'impasse
dans lesquelles nous nous trouvons et
puis enfin monsieur le sénateur
salmon les décisions qui sont prises et
les propositions de la Commission
européenne sont faites et sont basées
sur les préconisations de l'fsa lesquels
travaux de l'fsa ont été aussi alimentés
par Lan alors on peut pas avoir la
science à géométrie variable en fonction
des convictions c'est l'fsa et l'an qui
disent un certain nombre d'éléments sur
le glyphosate écoutez l'an et mais
écoutezle toujours et pas selon vos
convictions ça sera mieux pour tout le
[Applaudissements]
monde monsieur le ministre vous le savez
parfaitement la fabrique du doute
fonctionne à plein régime aujourd'hui
avec des pseudo études scientifiques
payés par les grands groupes hier hier
l'amante le fossile le tabac aujourd'hui
les pesticides personne n'est dupe il
faut prendre vos responsabilité nous
avons une chance demain de remettre la
France à sa place dans le leadership ne
la gâchez pas ne faites pas en sorte que
demain nous ayons honte de la position
de la France le glyphosate c'est avéré
est un poison des métaanalyses le
prouvent tous les jours ce ne sont pas
des petites études faites par les grands
groupes la parole est au président
Jean-François rappin pour le groupe les
républiquains vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues tir groupé du paste-caléis
bien sûr le rouge et l'orange ces deux
couleurs sont désormais familières mais
si angoissantes pour les habitants du
paste-calais mes premiers mots iront
donc vers les sinistrés des deux
tempêtes et des inondations qui se
prolongent de depuis 3 semaines je pense
aux habitants sinistrés bien trop
nombreux ils n'ont plus de maison ils
n'ont plus de vêtements ni de chaussures
et leur regard est vide car désespéré
tout comme leur mère qui malgré leur
courage sont épuisé et à bout de
solution je pense au sinistrés agrico
qui n'ont plus de champ à semer plus de
bêtes à faire pâurer plus de légumes à
récolter je pense au sinistrés économiqu
qui ne peuvent plus faire fonctionner
leurs entreprises ni faire travailler
leurs salariés jamais nous n'avons connu
castrophe d'une telle ampleur avec une
étendue géographique si importante
jamais nous n'avons autant souhaité la
solidarité locale et nationale pour
venir effacer le désespoir d'un avenir
sombre encore à découvrir au-delà de la
solidarité des collectivités locales qui
est déjà précisé et qui va s'accroître
au-delà de la solidarité nationale qui
est pleinement assurée dans l'urgence
par nos préfets et leurs services la
représentation nationale et les
collectivités attend des précisions pour
le futur de ces sinistrés
nous avons aussi besoin d'une solidarité
européenne comme je l'ai dit au
président de la République hier je
souhaite que l'on puisse d'ors et déjà
activer les trois mécanismes de soutien
européen le premier mécanisme qui est
celui de la protection civile de l'Union
européenne le deuxième et le fond de
solidarité de l'Union européenne qui
peut être activé pour des catastrophes
régionales et enfin l'instrument d'aide
d'urgence j'ai deux questions
pouvez-vous nous préciser les
dispositions nationales qui seront
prises par le gouvernement et nous
préciser si l'Union européenne est déjà
sollicitée dans la gestion de cette
catastrophe
naturelle pour vous répondre la
parole Monsieur
bchu Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
oui nous avons activé les dispositifs
européens et nous allons même un peu
plus loin puisque le président de la
République a souhaité que nous puissions
faire une comparaison entre la manière
dont dont nos amis belges et hollandais
qui sont confrontés en ce moment même en
Belgique à des inondations du même type
mobilisent leurs mécanismes nationaux
quel type d'accompagnement budgétaire
quelle politique d'adaptation en amont
je pense que dans ce domaine y compris
vous l'avez dit parce qu'on a affaire à
un événement climatique horors norme
mais que nous avons des raisons de
penser qu'il se reproduira puisque les
experts nous disent qu'on aura des
épisodes de pluie intensees de plus en
plus nombreux tout en vivant des
sécheresses estivales nous devons
regarder comment d'autres se préparent à
ce type de dispositif
activation des dispositifs européens
comparaison de ce qui se passe et puis
dans le même temps vous me donnez
l'opportunité de valoriser aussi
l'action de Marc phenau avec le
déclenchement du dispositif sur les
calamités agricoles et les annonces
qu'il a fait ce matin à la fois pour les
départements qui ont été touchés par la
tempête siaran par la tempête Domingos
et par les inondations puisque ce sont
80 millions d'euros qui vont être
débloqués pour là aussi accompagner et
vérifier que les agriculteurs qui sont
concernés et je je join ceux qui
exploitent des fraises à Plougastel à
ceux que vous évoquez pour la betterave
ou pour l'élevage qui se retrouvve dans
le dénouement que vous décrivez si bien
nous sommes déterminés à utiliser tous
les leviers nationaux et européens pour
accompagner les sinistré de ces
territoire il y a une chose qu'on peut
pas faire et vous venez de le faire avec
beaucoup de justesse monsieur le
sénateur c'est qu'auudelà des chiffres
au-delà des mécanismes au-delà des
reconnaissances au-delà des labels que
nous ayons collectivement une pensée et
un hommage pour les élus pour les
bénévoles pour les associations pour les
employés municipaux qui sur le terrain
depuis des jours et des jours ne compte
ni leurs heures ni leurs peinees merci
d'avoir pensé à les cités ils sont au
cœur de nos pensées et je pense que nous
pouvons collectivement au-delà des
sinistrés les applaudir pour ce qu'ils
font depuis le 6
novembre monsur Rapin
monsieur le ministre je me tiens à votre
disposition et celle du gouvernement
avec les deux présidents de région du
département pour rencontrer la
Commission européenne parce que
finalement vous m'avez répondu sur les
les plans à mettre en place mais pas
forcément sur les financements et je
pense qu'il faut être précis là-dessus
deuxièmement je pense monsieur le
ministre preuve est faite et vous l'avez
entendu hier de tous les maires qu'il
faudra reparler de curage de faocardage
de fcinage de débroussaillage de bassin
de rétention pour nos cours d'eau à
l'écoute des élus locaux plutôt que de
dépenser trop d'argent en études qui
sont incessant tuant traînant et parfois
inu la parole est à notre collègue
Corine Ferret pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républicain merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il y a moins d'un
mois plus d'un millier d'ê soignants
d'infirmiers de sages-femmes et de
médecins dénoncés dans une tribune
publiée dans le journal Le Monde les je
cite dilemme éthique intena auquel ils
sont confrontés FA de lit et de
personnel dans nos hôpitaux partout dans
mon département le Calvados comme
ailleurs les soignants alertent sur la
dégradation sansf de leurs conditions de
travail ils indiquent ne pas avoir
choisi de travailler à l'hôpital pour
être contraint de trier les patients ou
d'être maltraitant il y a quelques mois
le service statistique du ministère de
la Santé indiquit que plus de 21000 lits
avaient été supprimé entre 2017 et fin
2021 l'essentiel du premier quinquen
d'Emmanuel Macron donc dans 173 villes
163 villes pardon de France les urgences
ont été ponctuellement fermées cet été
en raison de la démission de personnel
aujourd'hui encore il y a dans certains
établissements 30 % de lit fermés et
parfois même ce sont des services
entiers pas une semaine ne se passe sans
que l'état de délabrement du secteur de
la psychiatrie celui de la pédiatrie
victime d'un abandbon de l'État ne fasse
la une sans parler de toutes ces
maternités que vous avez laissé se
dégrader au point que plus personne ne
veut y travailler alors Monsieur le
Ministre sortez des logiques comptables
technocratiques allez-vous enfin écouter
les professionnels de terrain garantir
un nombre maximal de patients par
soignant comme le Sénat l'a voté et don
à l'hôpital public les moyens de prendre
correctement en charge les
patients pour vous répondre la parole au
ministre la santé
monsieurous monsieur le Président
Mesdames et et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la
sénatrice l'hôpital est singulièrement
l'hôpital public est dans une situation
difficile il connaît une crise il
connaît une crise qui a des racines
profondes et qui font écho en partie à
la question que votre collègue Bernard
Jomier posé tout à l'heure l'avantage
d'avoir un peu d'expérience c'est de
pouvoir aussi revenir sur certaines de
ses propres erreurs en 2017 le la
sécurité sociale la branche maladie
était à l'équilibre en effet mais sans
doute avons à l'hôpital avait-il été la
variable d'ajustement de ces dépenses et
sans doute que on était allé trop loin
dans la régulation financière à cette
période-là l'hôpital il connait une
triple crise une crise qui est issue de
la de la situation sanitaire et du covid
une crise des vocations et une crise qui
est liée plus ponctuellement à
l'inflation sur ces trois crises l'État
n'a jamais euh tourné les yeux n'a
jamais été dans une situation de dénis
l'augment a ation des rémunérations des
soignants elle n'a jamais été aussi
forte depuis 30 ans le segégure
investissement il va apporter 19
milliards d'euros même si évidemment ces
19 milliards d'euros sont érodés par
l'inflation dans les établissements de
santé nous sommes aussi nous avons été
aussi au rendez-vous pour la crise covid
avec le système de la garantie de
financement et madame la sénatrice si je
peux partager une partie de vos
évidemment une partie de vos constats je
j'aurais tendance à à à à me référer à
un un grand un grand parlementaire euh
qui avait l'habitude de me dire que sur
tous les samedis matins devant dans sur
le marché de sa commune sa commune
s'était rembouillée il y avait le
collectif de défense de l'hôpital qui
indiquait que l'hôpital était à l'agonie
que les soignants allaient tous
disparaître et bien écoutez
expliquez-moi après comment les patients
peuvent se dire je vais aller à la
maternité de Rambouillet je vais aller
aux urgences rambouillé je vais aller
faire ma chirurgie à rambouillé à force
de dire que l'hôpital est à l'agonie
malheureusement
certaines certains faits sont
autoréalisateur merci alors madame Ferré
on va revenir dans le
Calvados monsieur le ministre et alors
et alors nous avons votre réponse que
vous venez de faire nous nous l'avons
déjà entendu mainte fois de la part de
vos prédécesseurs mais forcé de
constater que la situation elle s'est
encore dégradée nos hôpitaux doivent
demeurer des lieux de soins sûr et
humain et les Français comme les
soignants attendent des actes
[Applaudissements]
forts la parole est à notre collègue
Laurent Duplomb pour le GRL
[Applaudissements]
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre aujourd'hui il y a
deux types d'acteurs ceux qui veulent
une agriculture qui rime avec
environnement et qui croit au progrès et
ceux qui considèrent que l'agriculture
s'oppose par nature à l'environnement et
veulent l'éradiquer je fais partie de la
première la Commission européenne du
Parlement européen en cohérence avec
avec sa doctrine décroissante fait
partie de la seconde dernière décision
en date dans le cadre de l'examen du
Règlement sur l'usage durable des
pesticides dans les zones Natura 2000
qui partait pourtant d'un bon principe
le Parlement veut désormais interdire
toute pratique sauf en agriculture
biologique dont on connaît la crise de
surproduction en résumé soit les
agriculteurs se convertissent et vendent
à perte soit il s'arrêteent tout de
suite autrement dit pour protéger ces
zones comme j'avais déjà prévenu il y a
2 ans ici on accepte de rayer
l'agriculture de la carte en France
Natura 2000 c'est 7 millions d'hectares
donc près de 5 % de la surface en
production frutière et 70000 hectares de
grande culture rien que dans la bosse
après le Green Deal cette nouvelle
décision décroissante des gens qui
préfèrent une agriculture importée est
contraire à notre souveraineté dont
votre ministère porte le
nom je vous le dis il y a deux C ceux
qui croient en une agriculture de
progrès et ceux qui veulent éliminer
l'agriculture je fais partie du premier
camp et je m'opposerai à ce ce projet de
décision européenne et vous monsieur le
ministre de quelquun faites-vous
partie répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs on est toujours
commis d'office d'être dans un camp ou
dans un autre mais en tout cas je suis
dans le camp de ceux qui défendre
l'agriculture et sa souveraineté
l'agriculture française et la
souveraineté française et européenne et
vous me trouverez toujours je crois que
vous le savez monsieur le sénateur dans
ce col après comment on fait une fois
qu'on a dit ça on a besoin à la fois de
trouver une trajectoire qui soit une
trajectoire économique vous avez raison
de le rappeler parce qu'il y Ava pas
d'agriculture s'il y a pas de modèle
économique qui permet de rémunérer les
agriculteurs et de prendre en charge un
certain nombre de demandes qui se leur
sont faites par la société ou de demande
d'évolution deuxième élément c'est
peut-être en cela que je diffère je
crois à l'agriculture de progrès mais je
crois que le statut quo serait la pire
des choses pour l'agriculture le
dérèglement climatique les dérèglements
géopolitiques et économiques vont
imposer un certain nombre de transitions
que nous devons accompagner pour les
agriculteurs sinon nous ferions une
erreur tragique sur le sujet que qui
nous préoccupe tous ici au Sénat et et
ailleurs que le sujet de la permanence
de l'agriculture française 3ème élément
sur le sujet sur lequel vous commencez
votre question que est réglementation
sûr d'abord vous dites je m'oppose à une
décision la décision n'est pas prise
premier élément nous sommes dans le
cadre d'un dialogue entre le Parlement
le Conseil et la Commission qui n'a pas
du tout abouti c'est une position qui a
été exprimée par la commission
Environnement le travail se poursuit
nous suivons ça de près avec Christophe
je pour qu'on puisse combiner une
trajectoire de réduction des pesticides
qui n'a pas été déterminée par ce
gouvernement il y a 15 ans qu'elle a été
déterminée cette trajectoire de
réduction des pesticides et en même
temps quelque chose qui permet de faire
en sorte qu'on accompagne les
agriculteurs dans les transitions ça
veut dire pas d'interdiction sans
solution et donc de regarder avec
lucidité les impasses je n'ai jamais cru
que les interdictions produisaient des
solutions mais il faut chercher des
solutions donc il faut chercher les
alternative donc il faut faire et mettre
des moyens sur la recherche enfin on
peut pas mettre en place un système qui
soit la mise sous cloche d'une une
partie de nos territoires et nous
partagons ce point de vue qui fasse
qu'en gros il y a une partie des
territoires dans lequel on dise pour la
forêt ou pour l'agriculture il y a plus
de production qui soit tenable
économiquement et donc c'est là-dessus
que nous tenons les positions de la
France y compris sur les débats que vous
avez sur la réglementation sûre monsieur
duplom monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on parle des zones Natura 2000
pas d en même temps comme d'habitude
votre gouvernement laisse passer ce
genre de projet simplement pour arrondir
les angles en fin de négociation mais la
porte à la décroissance s'ouvre toujours
un peu plus c'est toujours le même
renoncement et une fois de plus votre
gouvernement emportera l'entière
responsabilité
merci la parole est à Madame Annique
billon pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues qui voulons-nous protéger
toutes les 3 minutes un enfant est
victime de violence sex sexuelle chaque
année 160000 enfants sont victimes de
violence sexuelle au total 5 millions
d'adultes ont subi des violence
sexuelles dans leur enfance 92 % des
victimes ne sont pas entendues 3 % des
mises en cause pour viol sur mineurs
sont condamnés seulement qui
voulons-nous protéger c'est une
interrogation posée par le juge Édouard
durant coprésident de la civise entendu
par la délégation aux droits des femmes
la semaine dernière en 2021 le président
de la République a promis à toutes les
victimes qu'elle ne serait plus jamais
seule en 2021 la commission indépendante
sur l'inceste et les violences faites
aux enfants dit cvis a été créé pour une
durée de 3 ans ces travaux doit
s'achever ce 31 décembre aujourd'hui
elle est de devenue pardon un espace
reconstructeur qui accompagne les
victimes se pose donc la question de son
maintien en 3 ans la civise a accompli
un travail titanesque et salvateur la
Commission a recueilli recueilli près de
30000 témoignages en 3 ans la Commission
a fait des propositions fortes avec pour
seul boussole protéger enfin les mineurs
et condamner les agresseurs dans une
lettre publiée lundi avec la présidente
de la délégation au droits des femmes
Dominique Verrien et les membres de la
délégation nous appelons le président de
la République à maintenir la CIVIS
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple et appelle une réponse claire
comptez-vous maintenir la
si oui sous quelle
forme pour vous répondre la parole
monsieur ver ministre délégué
porte-parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Annique billon je
vous cherchais du regard merci soyez
assurés évidemment il y aura une suite
aux travaux de la sévise évidemment la
première ministre réuni sous son
autorité aura lieu le le 20 novembre
prochain un comité interministériel à
l'enfance qui va permettre de colliger
de compiler beaucoup de données certains
et un grand nombre d'entre eux vous
l'avez dit 30000 témignages d'enfance ce
n'est pas rien réunis par la civise
structure que je connais bien parce que
j'étais ministre en charge de la
question de la protection de l'enfance
lorsque la civise a été créée et je
connais je reconnais le travail
fondamental de cette de cette structure
c'est une structure qui a été cré pour 3
ans vous l'avez dit dans votre question
et se pose la question de ce qu'il va
advenir maintenant de quels outils
avons-nous besoin de quel type de com
faut-il aller vers une forme de CIVIS 2
faut-il revoir ou amplifier les choses
soyez assuré puisque vous l'avez dit
vous-même c'est l'engagement c'est la
grande cause du président de la
République c'est l'engagement de ce
gouvernement de la première ministre
parce que les chiffres sont terrifiants
ce que vous avez rappelé et ils sont
avérés un enfant toutes les 3 minutes
est victime d'inceste d'agression
sexuelle de violence sexuelle dans notre
pays quand on dit ça on a tous des h
cœur on a même tous franchement envie de
vomir et de crier mais comme on est ici
en responsabilité au lieu de crier et de
vomir et d'avoir des h le cœur on on a
la capacité d'agir et pour agir on a
besoin des acteurs on a besoin du
travail de terrain on a besoin des
professionnels donc encore une fois les
arbitrages seront donnés dans quelques
jours je comprends les mois qui peut
vous avoir saisi en tant Commission en
charge de de l'égalité femmes hommes je
crois au Sénat ou des droits des femmes
mais soyez assurés que l'ambition qui
était la notre il y a 3 ans elle est
encore plus vive
aujourd'hui madame
billon merci monsieur le ministre dans
votre réponse vous dites il y aura une
suite pour moi j'attendais CIVIS va se
poursuivre ou ne va pas se poursuivre je
voudrais vous dire qu'une assemblée ou
une institution elle doit toujours être
incarnée pour garantir son efficacité
nous en savons quelque chose au Sénat le
juge Édouard Duran avec son expertise sa
détermination ses convictions a démontré
qu'il était l'homme de la situation la
civice ne peut se passer du juge Édouard
Duran la parole est à notre collègue
Jacques gropérin pour le groupe les
républicains merci président merci
président mesames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues j'aimerais
associer ma question à notre excellent
collègue Stéphane pinoire monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale lundi
sont apparus sont ont été publiés donc
les résultats de l'évaluation nationale
sur les élèves de 4e en classe de
mathématiqu et de français vous avez
réagi à à cette annonce- là en disant
que vous étiez euh vous trouviez que le
résultat était inquiétant et vous avez
même dit que le collège était en
situation donc de difficulté qui
risquait d'être en pagne je peux vous
assurer qu'à ce jour le collège non pas
seulement est en pagne mais il est
véritablement en recul si on regarde
consultation après consultation
évaluation après évaluation depuis des
années on se rend compte véritablement
que les jeunes Français sont en
situation plus difficil et les résultats
baissent pour mémoire en 2000 la France
se situait dans le 1emier Tiers donc au
niveau des des rapports en tout cas des
évaluation PISA dans les pays de l'OCDE
en 2022 la France se trouve dans le 2è
tiers et par parallèlement et si j'osais
le dire concomitamment en tout cas le
budget de l'Éducation nationale augmente
véritablement en lorsque vous étiez
lorsque vous êtes arrivé aux affaires en
2018 au PLF le budget était de 51
million d'EUR 51 milliards d'euros en
2024 il est de 63 milliards d'euros soit
plus de 12 milliards d'euros le budget
de la justice trois fois le budget de la
culture on peut s'interroger alors que
parallèlement 44000 élèves de moins donc
sont apparus donc on s'inquiète donc une
seule question monsieur le ministre
deéducation nationale quelles sont les
réformes structurantes et puissantes que
vous allez nous proposer pour répondre
non pas à une crise mais plutôt à une
situation ou un échec majeur de notre
système
éducatif pour répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse Monsieur hatal Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Jacques groperin
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire des ma
nomination au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et et de la jeunesse mon
objectif c'est l'élévation du niveau
général de nos élèves et tous les
chantiers que j'ai ouvert doivent
concourir à cet objectif quand on
travaille pour restaurer l'attractivité
du métier d'enseignant on agit pour
élever le niveau de nos élèves quand on
travaille pour restaurer l'autorité du
maître à l'école on agit pour
l'élévation du niveau des élèves quand
on réforme le lycée professionnel comme
nous le faisons avec Carole Grandjean on
agit pour l'élévation du niveau quand on
agit pour faire respecter les règles de
la République les valeurs de la
République et la laïcité à l'école on
agit pour le niveau des élèves et même
quand on lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire indépendamment d'agir pour la
dignité des personnes on agit pour
l'élévation du niveau parce qu'un élève
qui est malheureux à l'école c'est un
élève qui ne peut plus apprendre à
l'école les évaluations qui ont été
publiées elles disent deux choses
d'abord elles disent que nous sommes en
train de changer la donne à l'école
primaire positivement la génération 2017
celle qui est entrée au CP quand le
président de la République a été élu en
2017 et que nous avons réinvesti
massivement pour l'école primaire elle
s'en sort mieux que les générations
précédentes évidemment on n'est pas au
bout mais cette génération qui qui est
rentré en 6e cette année elle s'en sort
mieux en lecture en écriture et en
calcul que la génération précédente il
faut continuer le collège vous l'avez
dit est un véritable sujet de
préoccupation songez qu'un élève sur qu
à l'entrée en 4e n'a pas le niveau de
lecture attendu en fin de CM2 un élève
sur qu je présenterai au début du mois
de décembre des mesures fortes pour
l'élévation du niveau général à l'école
et au collège je le dis je n'ai aucun
tabou j'ai d'ors et déjà avancer un
certain nombre de pistes sur la question
des manuels scolaires sur la question de
l'organisation en cycle sur la question
des groupes de niveau j'assume de le
dire parce que les enseignants me le
disent avoir dans la même classe des
élèves qui ne savent pas lire avec des
élèves qui lisent très bien ça ne permet
plus de progresser et ça finit par tirer
tout le monde vers le bas cette
proposition fait débat j'assume de
l'avoir mise dans le débat et je
présenterai au début du mois de décembre
des mesures fortes pour que nous
puissions avancer sur cet enjeu qui est
un enjeu pour nos élèves et pour notre
école aujourd'hui mais qui est un enjeu
pour l'avenir de notre notre pays je
vous remercie Monsieur
grosin Merci monsieur le ministre mais
j'entendais que vous nous parliez
peut-être d'une réforme du collège et la
réforme de ce collège unique qui existe
depuis 1975 et revenir vous nous avez
parlé des groupes de niveau je crois que
c'est pas tabou et vous avez raison de
le dire mais il faut aller encore plus
loin si on veut passer d'un collège de
la résilience à un collège de la
réussite il faudra certainement passer
par des réformes structurelles et au
sein du Sénat le rapport brissonquel
j'étais rapporteur vous proposera si
vous souhaitez des pistes parce qu'elles
sont efficaces merci bra
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre Allin Roiron pour le groupe
socialiste
écologiste monsieur le Président Madame
la première ministre ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre des
solidarité des familles en 2018 le
président de la République avait annoncé
je le cite répondre au défi du
vieillissement la proposition de loi
mesure pour bâtir la société du bienill
Bien vieillir sera examiné la semaine
prochaine à l'Assemblée nationale une
enquête récente menée par la Fédération
hospitalière de France a révélé que 85 %
des épades se trouvaient en situation
déficitaire à la fin de l'année 2022 ces
déficits tendent à devenir structurel et
croissant dans ce secteur pour ne pas le
dire hélas ils le sont déjà j'ai été
alerté hier de la situation budgétaire
de plusieurs épades dans mon département
je donnerai l'exemple de l'épad de
Richelieu le bilan déficitaire de cet
épad atteint plus de 400000 € dans moins
de 3 ans il atteindra son seuil minimal
de fonctionnement et ne sera plus en
mesure de rémunérer ses employés cette
situation alarmante résulte de facteurs
multiples l'inflation des denraes
alimentaire le coût énergétique plus 33
% 2023 la revalorisation salariale des
des soignants lesquels n'ont été que
partiellement
compensés faites-vous le choix de
laisser nos aînés faites-vous le choix
de délaisser le personnel des épades qui
travaillent dans des conditions déjà
très difficiles l'État doit être à la
hauteur de ces enjeux je suis persuadé
que l'ensemble de mes collègues ici
présents dans cette hémisyle seront
d'accord avec mes propos alors madame la
ministre ma question est simple et
attend une réponse concrète le
gouvernement envisage-t-il de mettre en
œuvre des compensations financières
pérennes et intégrales le gouvernement
compte-t-il s'attaquer de front à la
question du 3e âge et des épades pour
assurer à nos aînés un accompagnement de
leur vieillissement à la hauteur pour
vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre des solidarités et des familles
madame Aurore berger vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le le sénateur la question que
vous posez elle est essentielle au
regard du défi démographique qui est
devant nous en 2030 20 millions de
Français auront plus de 60 ans il faut
je crois qu'on sorte collectivement sans
doute d'un défi et d'un dénis individuel
et un dénis collectif et puis vous
l'avez dit il y a la situation très
critique aujourd'hui de nos épades
700000 Français aujourd'hui sont dans
ces établissements on a donc mis en
chose mis en place plusieurs éléments
d'abord un fond d'urgence amorcé et
débloqué par la première ministre cet
été de 100 millions d'euros de manière à
répondre encore une fois à l'urgence
conjoncturelle qui a fait que
l'inflation l'augmentation des
rémunérations la question des prix de
l'énergie et de l'alimentation fait que
parfois on a des situations
conjoncturelles qui méritent une réponse
immédiate évidemment des éléments plus
structurel qu'on a pu annoncer avec la
première ministre lors des Assises des
départements de France la semaine
dernière deux réponses dès 2024 nous
allons augmenter la compensation de
l'État parce que nous allons via la CNSA
augmenter de de 150 millions d'euros les
compensations du au département au titre
de laap et de la PCH et puis surtout une
refonte en profondeur des fonds de
concours que nous amorçons avec
l'ensemble des présidents de département
pour 2025 pour enfin que les fonds de
concours aient du sens qu'ils soi moins
nombreux en gros on arrête d'empiler des
fonds de concours et des politiques
publiques pour avoir des politiques
publiques beaucoup plus lisibles et
augmenter ainsi la prise en charge qui
sera faite par l'État ce que nous avons
mis sur la table et je crois que les
départements sont en accord avec cette
proposition c'est qu'à partir de 2025
50 % de toutes les dépenses nouvelles au
titre de l'autonomie soit prise en
charge par l'État via la CNSA c'est un
engagement majeur que l'État va prendre
qui est en corrélation encore une fois
avec le le défi démographique qui est
devant nous vous l'avez dit on reprend
l'examen à partir de lundi d'une
proposition de loi qui pose des bases
importantes sociétales et de
reconnaissance des professionnel je ne
doute pas que ce sera enrichi évidemment
au Sénat du moins je l'espère et enrichi
aussi dans le cadre de nos échanges sur
le PLFSS notamment avec la fusion des
sections soins et dépendances par
exemple je vous remercie la parole est à
notre collègue Christina Pluchet pour le
groupe les ré merci merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre le 8
novembre dernier par la voix de sa
présidente Madame vlen la Commission
européenne a recommandé officiellement
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
avec l'Ukraine C favorable doit être
ensuite approuvé à l'unanimité par les
27 lors du Conseil du prochain Conseil
européen les 14 et 15 décembre à
Bruxelles sans évoquer la question
diplomatique que pose cette initiative
dans un contexte de recherche de paix et
de désamorçage du conflit je
souhaiterais vous poser la question
fondamentale de la préservation de nos
intérêts
agricoles vous revenez d'Ukraine vous
avez annoncé je cite uvreer au
renforcement de la coopération agricole
entre nos deux pays travailler avec eux
sur le chemin de l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne et invoquer la solidarité des
agriculteurs dans le contexte de
l'ouverture du marché européen aux
produits agricoles
ukrainien monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur vos
intentions si la position favorable de
la France ne fait désormais aucun doute
êtes-vous bien conscient du désarroi des
agriculteurs français pris en lesau
entre des normes européennes toujours
plus exigeantes et complexes une
ouverture toujours plus grande à la
concurrence avec la multiplication des
accords de libre échange et une envolée
du cou des intrans et de
l'énergie monsieur le ministre quels
intérêts
défendez-vous votre dernière déclaration
largement relayé par vos soins sur les
réseaux sociaux sonne comme une volte
face pour de nombreux syndicats
agricoles nous ne pouvons pas prendre le
risque de sacrifier nos intérêts comment
allez-vous protéger l'agriculture
française dans une telle
perspective B vous répondre la parole de
ministre de l'Agriculture de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur F
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateur madame la sénatrice
merci de votre question il y a aucune
volte face au contraire je suis venu en
Ukraine réaffirmer plusieurs choses
d'abord à la vérité en Ukraine se joue
beaucoup de choses qui qui relèv de
l'avenir de l'Europe et de l'avenir de
l'agriculture en Europe et de
l'agriculture française aussi la
première chose que je suis venu dire en
Ukraine c'est le soutien indéfectible de
la France et de l'Europe à l'agriculture
et aux agriculteurs Ukrainiens quand
vous êtes sur des territoires ou du fait
des bombardement du fait de la pollution
j'étais dans une chèvrerie où le la
ligne de front était à 500 m voyez bien
dans quelles conditions pour prod ces
agriculteurs ça me paraît la moindre des
choses que de dire que nous sommes à
leur côté y compris dans la
reconstruction y compris dans la
dépollution pour que le potentiel
agricole ukrainien puisse se faire
deuxième élément de la réponse parce que
la solidarité n'empêche pas la lucidité
sur les enjeux qui sont les nôtres et
donc la lucidité qui sont qui sur les
enjeux fait que l'Ukraine est l'une des
grandes puissances agricoles mondiales
et que dans la perspective de
négociation qui pourrait s'ouvrir
attendons les décisions du Conseil du
mois de décembre dans la perspective de
ce qui été les préconisations de la
Commission européenne faut être vigilant
à deux choses la première c'est qu'il
n'est pas possible que dans cet objectif
là il n'y ait pas de convergence des
modèles et donc des contraintes qui
seraient lié à l'agriculture ukrainienne
comme elle se elle se pèse ou elle se
propose sur le continent européen
l'union de l'Union à 27 sinon évidemment
on aurait des distorsions de concurrence
qui serait trop faible et donc il faut
qu'on accompagne nos amis ukrainiens et
nos amis agriculteurs Ukrainiens dans
une convergence sinon évidemment on
aurait des distorion qui serait trop
forte et donc c'est un élément qui est
un élément important c'est comme les
clauses miroir sur les accords de
commerce deuxè élé il y a deux solutions
soit on rentre dans cette logique là en
coopération avec les Ukrainiens parce
que nous avons besoin de que l'Europe
soit plus encore une puissance agricole
une puissance qui garantis sa
souveraineté et la sécurité alimentaire
y compris à s frontière parce que je
préfère travailler avec des alliés comme
les Ukrainiens qu'avec d'autres qui vont
nous faire une pression alimentaire sur
la sécurité alimentaire comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui de Monsieur Poutine à
nos frontières extérieures et donc si on
arrive à coopérer plutôt qu'à rentrer en
concurrence si on arrive à faire
converger les modèles on y gagnera tous
et donc c'est bien ça qui est l'enjeu et
c'est bien ça que je suis venu
réaffirmer compris en signalant à mes
interlocuteurs les distorsions de
concurrence qui aujourd'hui pénalisé je
pense à la volaille ou je pense à
d'autres domaines le sucre par exemple
que vous connaissez bien dans votre
région qui peuvent pénaliser nos
agriculteurs discours de vérité et
discours de souveraineté collectif merci
Madame plucher oui merci merci monsieur
le ministre pour votre réponse mais moi
je voulais rappeler je voudrais vous
rappeler une petite chose depuis que
l'Union européenne a suspendu les droits
de douane par solidarité à l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui on a le poulet industriel je
dis bien industriel hein ukrainien qui
afflue sur le marché français au
détriment de notre filière d'excellence
donc il est vraiment temps de défendre
avec force l'agriculture française notre
souveraineté alimentaire doit être une
vraie priorité nationale merci
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Bruno rjoin pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre du
Logement devant le fiasco de votre
politique du loge
je vais vous en rajouter une couche
monsieur le ministre en effet sommet de
se mettre aux normes dans des délais
intenable les petits propriétaires
bailleurs concernés par les rénovations
thermiques ils sont nombreux en France
font leur compte et ça ne passe pas en
terme d'équilibre financier si pour les
secteurs géographiques des métropoles
avec des loyers plutôt élevés on peut
peut-être tendre vers un équilibre sur
un nombre d'années acceptable ce n'est
absolument pas le cas dans des
départements ruraux comme le mien et
d'autres en raison du faible niveau des
revenus et surtout des loyers ces deux
secteurs ont malheureusement un point
commun c'est que le coût des travaux
voyez-vous est quasiment le même comme
le montrent les devis réalisés ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
qu'allez-vous faire pour que la ruralité
ne soit pas une fois de plus pénalisée
par une politique nationale
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégé en charge du logement
Patrice
vergr monsieur le monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur rejoint
voilà je vous cherchais du
regard le sujet que vous évoquez est
effectivement important la rénovation
énergétique des logements en secteur
rural je le disais moi-même ici dans cet
hémicycle il y a une semaine dans un
département comme la Creuse c'est plus
d'un logement sur deux aujourd'hui qui a
un classement en diagnostic de
performance énergétique de niveau F ou G
donc on voit effectivement l'enjeu le
gouvernement il répond à travers de
nombreuses mesures et en particulier la
réforme de l'aide à la rénovation
énergétique qui va se mettre en œuvre à
partir du 1er janvier 2024 il répond
déjà très concrètement prenons un
exemple puisque c'est cette aide pour
aller jusqu'à 90 % du montant des
travaux pour les ménages très modestes
que vous avez évoqué dans votre question
mais prenons un exemple d'un ménage de
classe moyenne entre le 5e ou le 8e
desciles le montant des de l'aide par
rapport aux travaux sera de 60 %. donc
pour 55000 € de travaux on peut imaginer
33000 € d'aide auquel on peut agiter
évidemment l'aide des collectivités
locales qui peut exister mais aussi par
exemple puisque vous avez évoqué des
loyers modérés l'aide du dispositif loc
avantage qui permet de bonifier cette
aide
je rajoute qu'ensuite sur le reste à
charge nous avons prolongé l'coprê à
taux zéro aujourd'hui et puis surtout le
dispositif fiscal du déficit foncier que
vous connaissez qui permet de déduire
les charges des travaux des revenus
locatifs et doubler jusqu'en jeevier
2025 pour des travaux qui permettrai
d'atteindre la performance de classe D
si j'ajoute à ça le de Normandie que
nous avons également poursuivi
dispositif fiscal la prime à la sortie
de la vacance il y a une multip it
d'aide qui permettent d'aborder
effectivement ces enjeux là aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il faut les saisir tous la
loi logement permettra si ce n'était pas
suffisant de renforcer encore ces
dispositifs pour la ruralité vous voyez
monsieur le sénateur la ruralité n'est
pas abandonnée loin sans faut je vous en
remerci monsieur rejoint j'aimerais vous
croire Monsieur le Ministre mais
voyez-vous ce gouvernement dans le
domaine du logement a réussi un triple
exploit jamais inégalé aujourd'hui la
construction de logement neuf est
bloquée l'achat vente de logement ancien
est au plus bas depuis des décennies et
là vous nous faites entrer dans un
blocage du locatif avec une situation
qui va être dramatique donc tous les
clignotants sont au rouge alors
voyez-vous en politique comme ailleur il
n'y a aucune honte à essayer de corriger
un certain nombre de dispositifs qui ont
été mis en place ce serait tout à votre
honneur ce serait aussi faire preuve de
cour
et en politique le courage souvent ça
pay
merci merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
avons terminé avec les questions au
Gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le vercredi 22 novembre à
2023 15h précise je vais suspendre la
séance sera reprise à 16h30 pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 la séance est
suspendue